Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is always my job to deconstruct world class performers of various types and
across many disciplines and today we have Liz Lambert on the show.
Liz,
thanks so much for taking the time,
so happy to be here.
I'm thrilled to have you finally in front of me and I'm going to give people a
little bit of context.
So who is Liz Lambert,
Liz Lambert at the Liz Lambert at Instagram and Twitter first purchased a seedy
motel on South Congress Avenue 23 years ago and transformed it into Hotel San
Jose,
which has become known today as the Quintessential Austin hotel.
The success of Hotel San Jose,
which sparked a revitalization in the city is now thriving south Congress
district,
which we'll definitely talk about.
Led her to launch bunkhouse group,
a hospitality company,
founded on the pillars of design and music and community driven experiences.
Since then,
she's expanded bunkhouses unique hotel portfolio to include El Cosmico,
which has been recommended to me about a thousand times the community lodging
concept in Marfa.
Also a place worth talking about the iconic Austin Motel and renovated Motor
Court Hotel and hotel St Cecilia where I was just two nights ago.
In fact,
a 14 room secluded estate in Austin Hotel,
Havana,
depending on where you are.
The historic property on San Antonio's riverwalk and most recently is added
bunkhouses first International Hotel Hotel San Cristobal Baca in Todos,
Santos,
Mexico and the first non Texas property a domestically the Phoenix hotel to
their hotel portfolio.
Lamberton bunkhouse also operate Joe's coffee,
the Popular Austin Coffee Shop,
which I frequent myself and that currently includes three locations and an east
side event space.
Fair market.
Also located in Austin.
They've really gave you a full,
oh,
we're going to cover covering all the basis layer.
It's 4,000 hotel.
The Magdalena is currently in development and is slated to open on South
Congress in 2020 maybe 2019.
We'll see maybe 2019 wow.
I head of schedule.
That's unusual.
I would imagine
it's a moving target and there's so many places that we could start with this.
And we have some mutual friends,
uh,
which,
which makes me always a bit more comfortable and excited to jump into things.
But I thought we would begin with the last days of San Jose.
Now this is a documentary and I hold you fully accountable for keeping me up way
past my bedtime.
I,
I've watched most of it.
I haven't seen all of it.
I'll be honest,
uh,
because I had to go to bed last night at some point.
There's a surprise ending really well,
it's,
it's a documentary on Hotel San Jose's origins.
And I thought I would share a note from my assistant so my assistant doesn't add
notes,
too much of my prep documentation at all.
And this is her note quote.
I've watched most of the documentary on and off throughout the day.
Just,
just listened to her talk to the humanity of people.
The San Jose tells you everything important you need to know about her.
And I wasn't sure quite what that meant.
It was seemed a bit cryptic.
And,
uh,
I have to say a very impressed with the dock B.
Uh,
you must have captured so much footage and you did a really nice job of editing
for emotional impact.
I was,
by the way.
Okay.
I didn't edit and I never could have edited that and I've never would have been
in the doc had it been my,
yeah.
Your choice.
Could you tell people who don't know?
And I imagine that's a lot of people,
a lot of people.
Yeah.
I never released it about the doc.
And why didn't you release this?
I was trying to find it online so I could push it out to people.
You know,
it's terrible.
It is every year.
This is one of those things.
Every year it's on my list to do and I can never quite,
so this is a documentary and I'll tell you why.
I talked about why I never did.
Um,
this is a documentary that I did when I first bought the San Jose,
which I used to be a lawyer.
It was sort of a change of career inadvertently.
And I bought an old motel down on south congress.
Um,
I,
I have terrible Elsdon allergies today.
So sorry about it.
That's okay.
I was,
we were chatting that this is audio verite.
Yeah.
Truthfully,
um,
I Biden in the mid nineties,
I bought an old motel down in south congress.
I was a lawyer at the time that I'd basically just walked up to the door,
knocked on the door and there was a Taiwanese couple there that own the motel.
And at the time there was nothing on South Congress,
which is as you know,
a very popular area and on a hot spot,
cool area,
very hip.
And it wasn't a car on the street back then.
I mean,
honestly,
and um,
they were about to put the motel on the market and I sort of,
you know,
purse.
I told him,
don't do that yet.
Let me see if I could do something about it.
I ended up buying the San Jose not knowing anything about what I was doing.
Four,
$500,000.
My mother co signed a note and suddenly they handed me the keys and I'm as I'm
away and I knew nothing about running a hotel or a motel or anything,
knew nothing about business.
Really
paint,
paint a picture for people as to the clientele and what was the kind of the
state of affairs because people think South Congress now and they're like,
oh,
cool.
Like I have fancy Japanese food and I can go have a go have some Moscow.
Oh,
no,
no.
It was dicey.
I mean,
people didn't go down there at night.
There were no businesses on the street.
The continental club was there and had been there since 1957 and it remained,
um,
but really was no place to eat.
The first Schlotzky's was actually on south congress,
really tiny place,
but there was nothing down there.
And I had moved back into the neighborhood.
And,
um,
but I would go to the continental club alliance,
so sit on a bar stool there.
And I've watched the San Jose across the street,
which was an old motor court built in the 30s I Spanish colonial revival style
painted seafoam green at the time and it looked like it was empty,
but it was really,
because there were people,
it was full all the time,
but it was 30 bucks,
25 to 30 bucks a night and nobody really had luggage or cars and nobody really
came out during the day so it looked very quiet.
But at night it was teeming with life and it was,
you know,
there was your,
it was junkies and prostitutes and but a lot of good people too that were just
down on their luck for one reason or another,
couldn't pay a deposit first and last month's deposit or somehow something in
life had happened that dislodge them.
But you know,
they could get a hotel room for either a couple of nights or some people live
there.
They were residents that live there permanently,
but they just paid by the day or by the week.
I have so many questions.
I could do an hour just on this doc and it's not obviously because I have
anything to gain financially from pushing the docs.
It's not even available.
So I was going to tell you why it's not available.
Okay.
I shot the dock,
which was following I as an undergraduate,
I was a creative writing major with a concentration in poetry,
which just for background for folks,
and this is,
this is my,
my non linear style.
I apologize.
Uh,
where did you,
just a quick kind of bullets.
Where did you grow up and where did you do your Undergrad?
Yeah,
I grew up in west Texas and I did my Undergrad.
I started at Tcu in Fort Worth.
I'd had a brief stint at Stanford and then I finished at ut.
So I've seen the world doing creative writing and humanities.
So I had a lot with a concentration in poetry.
So I had a lot of friends who were writers or who,
um,
you know,
I've wrote a lot at the time.
Even back then,
whether it was journaling or poetry or whatever it was,
and friends would encourage me to write down when I stopped my law job at some
point when I knew,
I knew I was in over my head or in a good way over my head at the San Jose.
But I needed to do something with the motel.
I couldn't continue on at $30 a night with people stealing sheets and bleeding
on sheets and burning cheats,
you know,
like your name it.
Um,
but I,
people kept encouraging me to write down things that happened during the day
because I would tell stories at dinner,
I go to dinner with friends and it would be absolutely absurd or crazy in the
first five or 10 minutes.
You see examples.
Yeah.
So I,
um,
I didn't have time to write it down because I was literally like,
you know,
the,
the place,
the place had been redone in the seventies I think was the last time.
So it had shag carpet still.
So you can imagine as you tried to vacuum that shag carpet,
what is like,
I mean,
there were definitely people,
it was definitely a place where you did drugs.
It was definitely a place where you had whatever homeless pet you might have.
I mean it was just like,
and then the housekeeper that had been at the,
the motel before I bought it,
there were,
uh,
a husband and wife the sues who were awesome people,
but they were the only employees besides Mr Woo Hoo.
I swear to God was like two years of luring God in almost blind.
And he was a housekeeper.
So like the state of the rooms going now,
we got there were just,
I mean,
I think of a hold and uh,
and I cleaned rims for quite a while,
so I was so busy that I wasn't writing things down and there was no journaling.
There was no,
that kind of thing.
But I did find a camera,
it was right when those little pocket cameras came out.
There was a little Sony PC seven.
And,
um,
I got one of those instead of,
I just started talking to people,
people knew the camera was there,
I put it up,
the front desk had a little glass thing that you slip money through and I just
duct taped it to the front for a while and then when I would go out to knock on
doors or kick people out or collect money cause it wasn't like you came and paid
on a daily basis,
you really,
I had to chase down money and so I would just take it with me.
And um,
when I was done,
I was really lucky at the time that I had a friend who was um,
at Afi as in cinematography,
American Film Institute.
Got It.
Uh,
her name is Jen Lane and she just now is the producer of the new queer eye.
Super popular.
Yeah.
And um,
she was one of my good friends and then she had a friend named to Briesewitz who
is a producer now as well,
but a very well known a cinematographer before she became a producer.
She shot the first three seasons of the wire and that's why the wire looks like
it does.
Wow.
So they were both in film school and they came down and I said,
you guys come help me shoot.
Because they were both directors of photography,
what we're studying.
And they were awesome because not only do they shoot some B roll and then when
it was ready to shut the motel down,
they shot the last three weeks,
but outta also has encouraged me.
You said,
um,
audio verite.
That's exactly what she told me.
I was really worried about a big microphone and stuff,
but nobody would have talked to me.
Right.
You know,
like she was like in,
don't worry about your film style.
Just talk to people.
And the story is compelling enough.
And that was,
those were words of wisdom and it is,
as long as you could hear it right,
you know,
it was going to be okay.
You didn't need a huge microphone to stick in somebody's face.
Just make sure it was audible enough.
So you have this,
you have some incredible footage
and I mean you really do capture,
I'm searching for a word besides humanity because it seems too high concept
maybe for,
for for what I'm trying to convey,
but you,
you captured the,
okay,
the vulnerability and this sincerity of so many different types of people,
of all different colors of all different types who are completely marginalized,
discarded these sort of invisible people.
And uh,
I
watched this and I was having just a bitch of a day yesterday and I was feeling
sorry for myself and I was talking to friends and we were commiserating about
various things and I've had a,
what I would consider in my life,
a,
a bit of a hailstorm of a week.
And then I watched this and I was just like,
you asshole God,
you should get down on your knees every day and just either thank God that you
have the bed that you have to sleep in,
that you have the food that you have to eat.
It's,
it's,
it was really humbling and you're holding this footage,
you have these stars to be helping you.
Why not?
Put it out.
I kept busy.
I mean,
here's the thing,
I will help you put this thing out.
Let's do that.
I would love that.
It's,
it's last three years.
It's been at the top of my list and I keep having people that say they'll help
and then you know,
everybody's busy and so it was,
I can,
I will commit right now publicly.
Like I will help you put it out.
So happy about that.
It's,
it's,
it's very,
as long as you're not expecting like a,
a full blown red carpet theatrical release if you just want it to be available.
I just want it to be available.
So what happened was Brian,
one of was done it,
you'll see the,
the doc ends as I close the door when we close the San Jose,
we fall during the,
the footage.
What?
During the documentary we follow five or six people that are permanent residents
at the San Jose.
Again,
I've,
it's just shooting on the fly,
kind of keeping a video diary.
And so I would turn the camera on myself every once while I never,
even when I began editing and realized that I couldn't edit it,
I had 90 hours of footage.
I mean,
there's so much good stuff in there,
but there was no way I was going to be able to tell a story.
So another friend of my friend Jen from Afi,
Tina Bizarro,
whose works in the business still today,
uh,
I hired her to edit,
but I didn't have her edit until about four or five years into the San Jose
being open.
And so it was hilarious because she would see people that might have passed
through the footage or the documentary and they would have no idea who she was,
but she spent hours and hours with watching them and you know,
she wouldn't be hey.
And they'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
way too much,
that kind of thing.
But she did an amazing job and she gave compelling reasons that I should also be
a character in the movie because it wasn't just about,
it was also about my story in about me living there as part of a community.
And the struggle I was having.
Everybody had a struggle,
different struggles.
But you know,
one of the remarkable things is that they're all behind me,
the folks that live there and generally.
So can I,
can I pause for a second?
Yep.
So there are a few like lilypad hops that I want to know more about.
So first is you went to three places for undergrad focusing on creative writing
with an emphasis on poetry.
Why did you go to three places and how on earth do you go from there to law?
Let's start with that.
Um,
I went to three places because my family were,
I'm from West Texas.
My,
my parents met at Tcu,
my grandfather played football for Tcu.
My Dad played football for Tcu and my oldest brothers played football for Tcu,
everybody and the,
and the kind of cousin group,
everybody went started at Tcu.
And I got there in Fort Worth is a lovely place.
I'm crazy about forth worth these days,
but I always knew it wasn't really going to be a fit for me.
Um,
and once I kind of got interested in creative writing the program,
there wasn't that strong.
I went to Stanford because I think it was aspirational of what I,
I thought that's where I would transfer.
I went there for summer school and then I,
I,
I was accepted into as a regular student at Stanford and I deferred.
Um,
I,
there were things going on with my family that I needed to come back to Texas
and I'm,
once I came back,
I just,
in terms of if you're comfortable saying,
man,
just interest sickness or divorce my parents yeah.
And,
um,
was really close to my mom.
And so it was,
I felt like I needed to be closer and I defer to semester and then I ended up
just going to ut.
I always loved Austin and if,
you know,
in the long run,
I'm really happy I did.
I mean,
when I arrived in Austin and the early eighties,
it felt like the place was made for me.
You know,
it just felt like home.
I hit about it,
you know,
I'm a Texan through and through and,
but there were a lot of reasons that I didn't really fit comfortably into other
parts of Texas.
I was gay at the time.
I wasn't even out.
And I was a little more creative.
Maybe I do,
I haven't found my place in Texas except for West Texas.
And,
um,
you know,
Austin,
it was the state capitol.
The university was huge.
It was,
you know,
this liberal place and more conservative state and the blueberries,
the blueberry and the tomatoes.
And then in the was amazing and there were rivers and lakes and you know,
it's,
it was,
I felt it felt like home for those people who have never been to Texas.
And there certainly lots of international folks listening and they have,
they may have the image of certainly of the cowboy hat and the boots,
but that's about it.
Uh,
when you say Texan through and through in other respects for,
for you,
what does that mean?
I'm from West Texas and you know,
that's,
there are a lot of people that grew up in Texas and never even make it to west
Texas is a big state for the you guys who don't know.
I mean,
although Jeff Bezos,
maybe unbeknownst to many people would be one of those people right in the
middle of West Texas is a good place to launch a rocket ship from.
Um,
and so,
you know,
it's,
uh,
I,
I'm,
I think sixth or seventh generation in the ranching business.
My family still ranches cow and calf operation.
And so there was a certain way Texas,
Texas is like another country for some people.
It really is.
I mean,
Texas.
That's right.
And that comes with a good and bad.
But for me,
mostly it's a,
it's a good thing.
Is there,
a friend of mine asked me when I was young and traveling,
he said,
when people,
if people would ask if you were in Europe,
where are you from?
I would say west Texas.
He's like,
that's really odd.
Most people wouldn't say that.
They would say none of that.
You say Texas,
you give the region no texts from,
I'm like,
well,
west Texas is so different than East Texas,
you know,
it is a enormous,
enormous state.
Yeah.
Uh,
so you end up in Austin.
How does the law come into the picture and why?
I've,
well,
so as,
as I said,
it was a humanities major,
which I'm forever thankful for.
And uh,
not,
and then I doubled down with a concentration in poetry,
but just,
you don't,
you know,
they're not looking for poets out there.
I don't think so much.
Um,
and so I,
I applied to go to,
I could go get my Mfa was really the path I was on and I graduate degree in
writing.
Right.
And I applied to one program at Sarah Lawrence and didn't get in.
And I,
I was like,
okay,
what now I knew that I was gonna need a little further education or some other
direction.
So actually,
the first thing I did is I got an internship at Texas monthly and worked there
before.
I didn't went on to work as a,
as a paid,
uh,
I don't even know what it was.
Paid employee,
I guess at Texas monthly for about a year and applied to law school during that
time.
My father always argued that,
um,
law school education was something I'd never be sorry about.
And it was actually the best liberal education you could get.
Do you agree with that now?
I do actually.
You know,
I'm as afraid at the time that it was killed.
Every bit of creativity in me,
you know,
that would somehow learning to think logically would dampen my ability to be
creative.
And I don't think that's true at all.
CIF,
you finish law school.
Do you work in the law profession before Hotel San Jose?
I did indeed.
So I went straight from law school to the DA's office in Manhattan and work
there for three and a half years or so and then,
um,
move back to Austin and worked at the Attorney General's office.
So it was a trial lawyer.
Um,
and again,
something I'll never be sorry about.
I made amazing friends that I'm still in touch with.
On a regular basis from that,
from a text thread to a occasional reunions.
Um,
but it also taught me how to think in a way that has served me really well in
business and in just in the world.
Um,
it,
it teaches you a form of rigor,
I think to be a trial lawyer,
to understand all the facts of any situation and to,
again,
to put it together.
So understanding the facts then of your situation at the time.
If I,
if I,
if I contrast,
contrast isn't the right word.
Sounds too judgy.
If I look at,
if I look at your path
side by side with the paths of other former lawyers I know,
which are many,
a lot,
right?
So maybe they say,
I don't want to do law,
but I'm going to do management consulting.
I don't want to do law.
I'm going to start a company with my friend or go to business school.
There aren't many who say,
I don't want to do law.
I'm going to buy a hotel that's,
that's full of drug addicts and prostitutes and so on.
So how,
why that particular choice,
how did that,
how did that come to pass?
Yeah,
I think partially it was serendipity.
Um,
I was in the right place at the right time on the right street.
What appealed about it to you?
Because I mean,
for a lot of people that would be,
it would have the,
it would have a repellent effect,
but you had an attract,
if you think about it,
it can come from the DA's office.
And a lot of the work I did was with a lot of the same,
I don't know exactly where that concentric circle is,
but you know,
a lot of the people I dealt with in New York and in the criminal justice system,
whether it was from a police ride along or just looking at the stories of people
every day down and out or in trouble or you know,
with when things get cross in one way or the other in their lives was not
something new for me that way in that I wasn't scared of the,
you know,
junkies and,
and um,
you know,
like I said,
again,
there were a lot of really good people there,
but we're at a,
at a moment in their lives really clear in the doc.
It's just part of the reason why,
yeah,
it's going to get released.
That's right.
But there were a lot of people hustling and whether that be a good hustle or a
bad hustle.
And I'm a big believer in hustling,
but there was some PR I got,
there's some pretty good grifters in there as well.
But so it wasn't unfamiliar mill you for me.
Um,
but I always was interested in design.
it's something that I,
uh,
had always enjoyed.
And my brother,
one of my brothers was,
um,
I had worked for ICF international contract furnishings.
Um,
kind of like no.
And um,
was I wish I knew.
No,
no,
no.
It's like a Nolan is a business that makes,
um,
it,
it probably started in mid century,
it was known for Florence Knoll and uh,
may issued a lot of classic,
uh,
furniture that you would see and you know,
like means Vandero did Steph or no,
or got it.
Okay.
Um,
design.
He was in design I should say.
Um,
and so it's a world that I was always fascinated by and it was really not this
clear path.
It was,
I,
and I've also always been,
I've always loved hotels.
Did you dislike law?
Um,
you know,
I,
I actually really liked the DA's office.
I liked,
um,
criminal law lunch.
I've,
there's a line in a Carolyn for Shay poem where she says there's nothing no man
won't do to another.
And that's fascinating to me,
like why we do what we do and why does our criminal justice system do what it
does and respond to the human condition the way it does.
And you know,
what are our rules and laws?
Um,
I found that fascinating.
And I also liked trial work.
I like talking to a jury.
I'd like the,
I liked the whole,
uh,
not just pageant of it,
but the actual truth finding mission.
I,
like I said like,
um,
I liked being a lawyer where it wasn't,
a lot of people think that the DA's office there,
their whole purpose is to get a conviction or you know,
be an arm of the police in one way or the other.
And it's not,
it's really to do justice or to do the right thing.
And that's an amazingly powerful thing.
He know a lot of people with my politics would have probably gone to the public
defender's office.
Can you explain why that's the case?
Well,
because why is that the case?
Why do people do with more liberal politics go to the public defender's office?
I think that the DA's office is often seen to be in alignment.
Pit Bull.
Yeah.
And in alignment with police,
the police and you know,
you've got to to do,
you know,
to fight the good fight,
you've got to be the person that that is,
um,
on the side of,
on the side of justice in the way of making sure that the con constitutional
principles are upheld and you're down in the trenches with folks at often or
sometimes wrongly accused.
And so it tends to separate out that way.
But at the time,
I really thought when it was in law school and thinking about going to a Da's
office that,
um,
it made sense to go to the place that had the power and the prosecutor's office
is the place where you can choose to bring a case or not.
Right.
I was also the first openly gay person hired at Manhattan Da's office.
1991.
Yeah.
Wow.
Crazy one.
Plenty of queers.
Their first openly,
openly.
And so the first year that I was there,
we actually marched in,
uh,
the Manhattan Gay Pride Parade,
like right behind the police department and in front of the fire department.
And my girlfriend at the time was,
she worked at the minority task force on aids.
So of course she was like marching with the House of Africa and they were like
having a blast and I was there with the DA's office,
the police and the fire department.
She'd be,
I'd be like,
come march with us.
And she's like,
no,
hell no.
But yeah,
so that was,
uh,
you know,
there was a lot of things that I,
you could talk for hours about that and you know what I learned and,
and um,
yeah,
I guess I'm just curious why,
why stop?
I mean a lot of people stay in La for a very,
very long time.
So you did have this moment,
you're at the continental club,
you see Hotel San Jose across the street,
you have this deep interest in design,
you have empathy for the people who are mostly not seen right.
Indoors during the day there.
You have all of that,
but you also have this potentially safe career in the legal profession.
Right.
So why stop?
A couple of jumps between there,
but said,
I stopped at the days of,
as you had a three year commitment and so I stopped about three and a half years
in,
right before you go on the homicide chart.
I think in year four I came back to Texas.
I think if you stay in New York too long,
you become a New Yorker.
Yes.
Speaking to someone raised in Long Island,
you have to be careful about that is a,
you have to be very,
very careful.
Yeah.
Done with the hat that happened to you.
So,
um,
I came back here and working at the Attorney General's office and that was a
little bit different.
I was traveling all over Texas trying cases and um,
and it wasn't as fascinating to me.
Um,
but it's still like being a lawyer.
And
a couple of things happened.
A friend mine died of AIDS related causes and that was a real jolt to the
system.
It was one of those moments where it was,
I felt you better do what you want to do.
It not what you're supposed to do or you know,
this is your one life in your one chance.
And so I think,
I think that probably happens for a lot of people.
You face mortality up close for the first time and that's either you just kind
of push it away or if you really invited in and,
and,
and grapple with it.
I think it's a life changing thing.
It's,
so,
it was,
for me,
it made me,
I always wondered about the San Jose down on South Congress and have a look at
it and kind of dream about it a little bit.
But that was the,
the,
that was the thing that got me out of the chair and across the street and
knocking on the door to find out if they never sell it.
And,
uh,
we,
we could,
we could spend the entire conversation just on the first few months of easily
the first month,
the first day of your experience at San Jose.
And I'm struggling with where to go to next because I kind of want to stay
there.
But,
but maybe what,
what I can do since it's sitting right here,
uh,
is talk about Christopher Alexander and certainly the other authors.
But I'm curious how you found your footing and your approach to doing what you
now do.
And so you kind of land there.
I'm writing,
oh my God,
you're doing every possible job.
I mean,
you're using a toothbrush to take some God awful stuff out of a sink.
I couldn't even identify what the sludge was,
is you don't want to know like,
yeah,
you don't want to know,
I mean,
syringes and say,
you're doing every job imaginable.
How do you figure out your playbook?
And when does,
when does,
when does Christopher Alexander,
not to overweight the importance of,
uh,
of these books,
but for those people who are watching,
you can see this is a book called a pattern language town's buildings
construction,
uh,
which has come up a surprising number of times on this podcast.
Has It?
It has,
yeah.
Interesting.
Well,
so at the time I,
I,
I thought that it was going to take the San Jose,
which was a 24 room motor court built in the thirties down on south congress,
an area of town.
That was it.
It was still pretty abandoned.
It was one of those places that it's not unusual at the time that there were
urban cores that when highways had come in,
it had redirected traffic and the small kind of mom and pop stores and urban
downtowns were bypassed.
But there,
you know,
obviously there was a lot of interesting architecture is still,
or buildings,
uh,
that,
that were because they were older or,
um,
and built at a time where they were on a really important avenue.
So Congress for those of you guys who don't know is a main thoroughfare in
Austin that leads directly to the state capitol.
And at one time it was the main avenue that went all the way to San Antonio,
probably 60 miles to the south.
And so it was a major thoroughfare.
So there were a lot of old buildings and businesses,
historic and otherwise,
uh,
along the way.
Um,
so I thought that I would just Redo this 24 room hotel motel.
What I didn't realize was that it was 30 bucks a night,
that if I were,
my idea was maybe it could be $75 and we could just redo it room by room and
then it would be this amazing place close to downtown.
I had lots of friends of would,
you know,
from musicians to creative people to people that were going to visit their
friends in the neighborhood that would stay there.
Once I started trying to crack that plan a little bit,
I realized it was a marketing nightmare that most people that we're going to pay
60,
75 bucks,
we're on the highway and they wanted something that they can rely on,
like a motel six.
And I'm was,
you know,
if I did learn somebody downtown under South Congress where there were no other
hotels,
they weren't going to want to stay next to the crack head next door,
a mom and pop and their van didn't want to rent next to somebody with an arrest
for a warrant for murder.
I haven't worn a warrant out for murder.
Um,
so I mean it was true.
You saw it a little bit of the documentary.
Yeah,
the police were around.
I remember when the police first came,
did they have a drive around the San Jose because there was a big court yard
that was just a parking lot.
And when I first got there it was like,
no,
don't do that.
That looks bad for business and by,
you know,
is there a week?
And I was like,
can you guys come more off?
But,
um,
so I started to realize and I would go and get new things and kind of tried to
Redo the rooms one by one and w I get something new and it would be stolen or I
would get,
you know,
like it just wasn't going to work room by room.
I finally realized there was some footage also who were like,
what happened to the TV?
The TV's destroyed.
Like,
Oh yeah,
the last person who was in your left a gift for the new person.
Every one of these is a fucking mess.
But they're saying it's a fucking mess.
Let's see what's in here.
It's like,
oh,
you know,
and it's one of those things,
it's,
it is,
if you clean something up,
people are much more like if you respect people,
people are much more likely to respect a place or a thing or a person.
And the people that were living there,
I mean it was,
you know,
the bed,
the mattress was a bed springs that we're cutting you at night sometimes.
So it wasn't like,
of course you were going to like throw a TV out the window,
you know,
was a cycle.
It was a,
that I had real now I had this place now is trying to keep it afloat.
I had to have a plan in my plan at 24 rooms with not much money,
wasn't going to work.
And then I started going to banks to see if I could,
you know,
I,
I had gotten through school without even taking a math class,
you know.
And so now suddenly I needed to understand the basics of business or writing a
business plan.
And I couldn't read a spreadsheet.
I didn't,
I couldn't read the financial statement.
I didn't know what,
you know,
all of those small numbers meant.
And suddenly it was,
became really important to learn that skill.
And so I went and audited some classes.
The business school at University of Texas has a great business school and I
took some management and the service industry classes and tried to leave.
Finally worked my way through how to do a business plan.
It was so hard.
You know,
I do,
we do them all the time now and we,
you know,
do studies and we do market studies and you know,
it's,
it's a skill that I rely on as we look at different hotels in different markets
now.
We do it all,
all the time.
And it was such a foreign language to me.
So then I finally got through a business plan and I was headed go try to
convince them banks that they should low me a bunch of money to Redo this motel
on South Congress,
which at the time you couldn't convince a lot of locals,
even set foot on south congress at night,
much less spend the night down there.
So it was a process.
So what I was,
what happened,
this is a cliffhanger.
I finally got,
I finally took on some partners that believed a bit and,
and in the idea.
And so that gave me some,
they had some track record,
so they gave me some legitimacy.
How on earth do you convince the f the first person?
Because banks are banks are saying thanks,
but no thanks.
Yeah.
But people were intrigued those so I could get,
you know,
remember I was a lawyer and so I was just really selling it and there was a
change afoot in Austin.
You could fill it in the air.
People were starting to return to that neighborhood.
Um,
they'd be there.
There was,
it was a time that it was in the mid nineties and there was starting to be some
urban infill downtown.
And so it was right on the edge of,
of that being not completely implausible.
Um,
but it didn't help that I had absolutely zero experience running a business.
I mean,
that's what really got the banks.
They were like,
what?
I'm like,
no,
I can do that.
A promise.
It's not good enough.
My poetry resume.
So,
um,
it took a local bank at the end of the day,
the guy named Eddie Safdie who was at,
um,
it's now prosperity bank.
Um,
but it was liberty at the time,
um,
basically to underwrite it.
But it also was remarkably inexpensive.
The work we did,
uh,
in the,
in the bigger picture is something that we would never get away with now.
But I was there all day every day.
It was a really lucky to have like to the architecture firm out of San Antonio,
now also out of Austin to be my partners and believe in the project as well.
So I hate to bother you with just halting the story and jumping into the nitty
gritty,
but these are such important inflection points if you don't get the money
extensively,
not good things.
Oh No.
Proceed from there.
So we're talking about liberty and then prosperity.
Both good words,
right?
How do you convince that person?
How did you convince them?
What was the conversation where they're like,
okay,
how does it,
I mean I also applied for an SBA loan and it finally got,
it was partially funded by the SBA,
so that was great.
I have a business partner now that I'm still in business with who is a great guy
and it had a lot of experience in business and his wife had brought him the
proforma for the San Jose.
How did she get it from a friend of a friend?
Basically it got passed around.
Some of you're just,
yeah,
totally.
Just to you guys,
let me get these into circulation.
Exactly.
Again,
I didn't know what it was doing,
right.
I didn't know.
So it was just who knows who and she brought it home and wanted to invest and
he,
he still has the copy of it because when it,
when it showed that we would get $110 a night in year three or so,
he wrote in the margin of the pro forma.
No Way.
He totally didn't believe,
but
I don't know how I,
you know,
I'm tenacious and,
um,
I,
I don't know how I finally convinced the bank.
I mean,
again,
they did take a leap.
Um,
I'm sure there was some kind of personal guarantee that I didn't even know what
a personal guarantee was at the time.
I'm not sure it take it,
take my blood.
I mean,
at that point I had thought about selling the San Jose.
I probably took two years to really closed,
but at 95 we closed in [inaudible] 97
to December of [inaudible] 97 just start renovation.
So it had taken all that time.
I quit my lodge,
I'll just,
just to go try to find money to do some kind of renovation.
And in the meantime we decided to say just just so I'm clear,
you were doing your law job simultaneous with running the San Jose up to that
point in the beginning.
And then at some point I realized I had to go work on the front desk and I quit
my law job.
Um,
which was crazy too.
You know,
I have to give it,
you know,
my mother's been gone for about five years now,
but I can't believe that they didn't think it was the craziest thing are done.
I mean like making no money.
My father would have pointed out that it was just at the point I became a really
good trial lawyer that I just jumped ship you now.
Which I mean,
I guess,
you know,
I don't know,
even in hindsight,
but I knew that I had,
I felt compelled in some way.
Again,
I'm really dogged and really,
you know,
I'm going to follow it down.
Once I decided that that's what I wanted to do,
but I got to say there were nights,
I don't know why isn't always nights that I laid awake and really thought about
selling the San Jose.
I'm probably two or three times I got really serious about it.
I thought,
there's no way I'm ever going to be able to do this.
It's too hard.
And um,
I just somehow powered through.
Why didn't you sell it?
Who would have bought it?
Right.
Good answer.
That is,
it is a fair answer.
So you finally get the money.
You close for renovations.
What do you do?
Is there anything that you did that you no longer do?
Were there things that you did where you're like,
oh,
that actually became part of my Palette as an artist,
so to speak?
Yes and no.
Yes and no to both.
I mean there,
there are ways that,
um,
it was extremely inefficient.
Um,
nobody would ever let me do what I did then now.
But you know,
it was,
I was learning on the job.
It was also really low risk.
I mean,
we think about it,
we'd look at in,
in,
in the hotel business,
you look at the price you pay per key when you're talking about selling or
buying a hotel key.
Yeah.
Perky,
perky,
perky per room,
per room.
So is the,
the general notion is,
um,
when you're talking about what a hotel is selling for,
what you're into it for,
what you can develop it for,
whether it's a good deal,
um,
you've taught,
you take the total price of the project from the land,
all the soft costs,
all the hard costs,
all the working capital,
everything you have in it to get the doors open,
all the furnitures,
fixtures,
equipment,
put that in a bucket.
And then divided by the number of rooms and that gives you the price per key of
what the hotel costs,
if that makes sense.
It does.
Yeah.
So I,
we were into the San Jose at the day.
We opened the doors for $100,000 per key,
which is super inexpensive.
Um,
if inexpensive,
inexpensive,
got it at the,
at the end of the day.
So it was low risk.
I mean,
and I was on the front lines,
I'm sure.
Again,
I had a personal guarantee and I was there every day working like crazy and lake
Flato though the architecture firms that I've worked with repeatedly since they
were also there every day.
And so again,
okay,
the question was,
are there things that I did then that I've,
I would never do again?
And then are there things that I did then that became part of my Palette?
Um,
yes.
And,
and looking back on it,
I think what I did intuitively there is something that we do as an organization
on a regular basis.
Now,
whenever we're looking at a hotel.
And that is to say that,
um,
I was interested in what the neighborhood wanted and needed and something that
the place had been there since the 30s in,
in the South Austin neighborhood.
And so I wanted to look around and look at,
um,
the,
the hotels that are most interesting to me are part of a neighborhood or part of
a community.
There's a places when I was growing up,
my granddad who was a rancher didn't have an office.
So he would go to the local hotel and sit in the lobby and do business deals and
you know,
get his shoe boots shined.
I get his haircut.
You could do that in the lobby of a hotel.
It was a place where people met and whether you were from out of town or you
were a local,
often times,
you know,
like a real cornerstone of the community or real and important place to meet for
the community.
Um,
so those were the kinds of things that interested me the most.
So it was one of the first things I asked is how do we serve this neighborhood
and South Austin?
And one of,
obviously the first thing is when we were directly across the street from the
continental club.
So what did musicians need?
And because at the time,
musicians where some of our most frequent guests when we were 30 bucks a night,
because you know,
they were coming through town in the van and they were looking for a cheap hotel
and a lot of times they might be wasted enough that they didn't notice how bad
the bad was.
Carpenter,
anything else.
And then we also have people that were spilling out of the continental club
sometimes late at night,
but um,
and that the neighborhood was starting to change and people were starting to buy
homes downtown again or in Travis Science.
Um,
we also started a coffee shop that opened my brother and I did a month before
the San Jose opened.
And that again was a need of the community.
So you were looking to fill the need.
That's what drove it.
It wasn't,
we want to make a coffee shop and it is,
what do people need?
People need to coffee shop,
let's do a coffee shop.
More than that,
we needed a coffee shop.
Ah,
this is a really,
I want to underscore this because it,
it comes up so frequently in people who ultimately
succeed in some capacity and entrepreneurship is,
it's so often starts with scratching their own itch and at least that way,
you know,
you have a market,
a one,
maybe,
maybe two.
It's not a complete speculation,
right?
So not to interrupt.
Nope.
When you think of a,
a pattern language and you think of Christopher Alexander,
um,
if what I was doing intuitively gigantic books,
those on audio can't see it.
It's,
it's big.
You bludgeon a badger with it.
But,
um,
the,
what I was doing intuitively was a lot of what,
uh,
for those of you who don't know,
Christopher Alexander is a,
is a writer and a thinker,
um,
about architecture and about how we build,
and,
and more than that.
But for me,
he wrote a book called the timeless way of building,
which I have not written down.
And he wrote a pattern language,
which was basically his idea was looking at all the old villages and towns and
communities that were,
you know,
throughout the world that have been there for centuries.
And his point was that people figured out how to build intuitively more southern
current at the time.
And probably today,
current architects today who are responding to how a thing looks rather than how
it functions.
And he's,
his argument is,
or his thesis is that we know intuitively,
you know,
where to put a fireplace or a hallway or you know,
a hub and spoke model in a small community.
Because if it's,
it's those ways of building that make a place feel more whole and more complete
and makes you as a person feel a more whole and complete.
It's sort of,
he calls it,
I think he calls it the quality without a name.
Yes.
I was so cold that the quality without a name.
What does that mean?
Well,
it does,
it referred to,
you know,
those places that you've been to,
that,
uh,
buildings you've been in or places you've been in where it just feels right.
And it feels,
um,
calming rather than agitating.
It feels,
um,
like you are part of something in an in a bigger sense.
And I think,
you know,
part of that would be,
today we people design things today.
This happens all the time that they've never even been to the place where the
Tuscan village in the suburbs is going to be put.
You know,
like you're,
his argument is that you look around you and you see how things are built,
uh,
in the place you are and you look at,
you don't bring a building materials that would never exist in a place.
Um,
you,
you look at the ways of doing things that have been done for a long time and
that way you become the fabric of the place itself.
Yeah.
This book is so simultaneously intimidating.
It is and fascinating.
I mean,
they just turned a random page,
five 99 activity pockets and there's a diagram with
the average number of people,
area of a 150 people to 300.
Oh wait,
no p must mean something else.
300 something square feet.
And it's looking at the placement of umbrellas and what it looks like an Italian
pavilion and there's another section,
yeah.
Pocket of activity,
which bulges into the square with a picture from Italy.
And then there's a separate section.
And I was actually looking at this,
uh,
because I had a cabin construction project not too long ago.
And there's a section on the integration of outside and inside.
Right?
Well,
okay.
So I don't think the book actually is,
I think you're reading isn't the right way.
Meaning you should not sit down and read that book from cover to count.
My God.
I mean,
it really is something that is,
you know,
he became,
uh,
he,
and he's still around today,
but he became a software.
Uh,
what would you say it is?
Designer of software is ideas about patterns.
The patterns are,
I think that happens over and over again.
You see in the natural order of things.
So if you're talking about an Italian plaza where the umbrellas are thinking in
your head,
how many times you've seen that?
Well there's a reason that there's a reason people on the ground design that
themselves because that's where human activity went to when we were doing no
cosmic cow,
which is
grab that because El Cosmico has probably been recommended to me by Texans,
uh,
more than any other hotel.
And then they're Austinites who do staycations at some of your places.
But let's describe El Cosmico because when,
when I did the introduction,
how did I describe it?
But I think that the community logic concept.
So what did what,
when you were designing El Cosmico,
I don't mean to interrupt,
but
no,
this is quite a ride.
I El Cosmico is it now 21 acres in far west Texas,
which,
uh,
in,
in the city of Marfa town of Marfa,
Marfa is one of the darkest places.
It is also about a mile high,
about as high as Denver.
And it is a more clear nights and clear days than your average place.
So you,
and it's one of the,
there's no real,
um,
the,
there's very little light because it's such a sparse area of the country.
I mean light pollution and,
yeah.
Yeah.
So if you think about it,
there's two main counties out in far west,
Texas,
Brewster and Presidio and I,
there's something like you can fit like 17 Rhode island's into one of those
counties and the,
I forget what the number is,
but the per capita,
the acreage per capita per person that's a redundant but is enormous.
Like you have,
every person has something like four square miles,
you know,
it's just like sparsely populated.
Im not,
not a lot of cloud cover and not a lot of light pollution for that reason.
My understanding is that uh,
astronomers or amateur astronomers,
but with PR,
nearly professional grade equipment or professional equipment traveled from all
over the country to go specifically to Marfa.
That's true for the new moon and things like that.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's incredible.
You can see the Milky Way,
which when I was growing up,
we could,
you could randomly see the Milky Way.
And how often do you see it now in places that aren't like Marfa or like Baja
California or you just weed,
there's too much light pollution.
We just don't see that anymore.
And you forget what an amazing feeling that is in the order of things to see
another galaxy.
So you have 21 acres.
Okay.
So I digress.
There's 21 acres.
We're right on the edge of Marfa.
It's a town of about 2,400 people.
And,
um,
I had done a small motel in Marfa and it's called the Thunderbird.
Um,
and,
and walked away from it.
It was a bad partnership.
Um,
we,
it wasn't going anywhere and I,
but I didn't know that I wanted,
it was interested in Marfa as a community.
Marfa as a community might it get my family ranches in the region.
I'd moved back from New York.
I really wanted to spend more time in far west Texas.
And Martha was a little bit on fire if you could say that for a community of
2,400 people because Donald Judd,
who is,
um,
you know,
one of the 20th century's most renounced sculptors,
uh,
was,
had made a home in Marfa and it had become an art Mecca for,
um,
a lot of folks.
See you have this crazy mix of artists and creative people and ranchers and
people that work on the land,
um,
in this beautiful place that for those of you guys who are from overseas might
think of it as the myth of the American West.
When you see those,
when you've seen giant,
are you seeing,
um,
movies,
westerns?
The,
the landscape we're talking about looks a lot like that.
Just stretching on forever and distant clouds.
So,
um,
oh Cosmico uh,
I bought this pasture basically that was on the edge of town and I wanted to
build a hotel or lodging experience of some sort there.
And uh,
I realized that it needed to be indoors and outdoors because that's one of the
reasons you go out there.
And,
um,
I didn't know exactly what I was going to do again at the time,
but realize that,
uh,
old trailers,
vintage trailers were a great way to get started putting hotels rooms up
quickly.
And so I bought,
I bought a few trailers and we redid them and I started falling in love with
trailers of that,
of the like fifties,
sixties time period.
Because those old Spartans and vagabonds and things like that are made with this
beautiful birch interior.
It was before they were making airstreams with
I,
you know,
I don't even know what the walls of a interior an airstream are,
but they trailers of that vintage had these beautiful wooden interiors that mean
you felt like you were in the belly of a ship or in a ship's Gavin.
And they,
we finished him with the yacht varnish at the time.
And so it was this,
it was like we put the first few trailers out there and it was like ships on the
desert,
you know,
and,
and I just fell in love with the whole notion of these,
um,
uh,
kind of nomadic ways of living.
And so we got some yurts.
Eventually we got teepees,
we've safari tents,
and it became this grand experiment to see how we would use the land.
So all of these,
all of the rooms were movable.
And so we kind of lived our way into it.
That comes back to Christopher Alexander and a pattern language.
It was really starting to have music festivals and parties there and people
living out there to determine what did the place need and how would people use
it.
So we've been talking about the outside inside integration,
uh,
and Christopher Alexander gives some great contrasting photographs for
illustrative purposes.
It seems based on the homework that I've done,
at least that you also think a lot about.
Well,
I'll quote here
and the Internet misquotes a lot.
So you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but here's,
here's the quote and this is part of a longer conversation of course,
but I hate it when I visited a hotel that hasn't put thought into the products
they placed in their room.
It's all part of the language of the place and the details that affect the guest
experience there.
So if we,
if we look at El Cosmico or you could choose a different example,
what are the things that people might notice in inside,
inside and outside and outside?
Yeah,
for I think for us at bunk house,
part of it is a whole experience like being at a hotel should be.
And you think of some of your favorite hotels.
It's not that you liked the bedspread or it was close to the highway,
you might have liked both of those things.
But I think probably the places you like the most are the most immersive and
you,
I think of it is storytelling in a way.
So every hotel that we do has everything from a soundtrack to oftentimes a color
or a color scheme that I'm repeats throughout a smell,
an incense.
Usually I get to Saint Cecilia,
we put Nug,
Champa big sticks and knock Chapa and the garden.
So as you're walking through the courtyard,
it's really subtle,
but it's something that strikes your senses and it will remind you of the saint
says of all the smells that you could possibly choose.
Why did you choose that?
The Saint Cecilia is a small hotel.
We have 'em off further back in the neighborhood office,
South Congress.
And it's very good selection of Tequila also.
I bet.
Um,
it's,
it's only 14 rooms,
but it was a main part of the Saint Cecilia is an old Victorian that was built
in the 1890s,
and then it has some bungalows that are scattered around about an acre and acre,
half of land.
Um,
and I,
in order for us to do a hotel for me,
there has to be a skeleton,
a story that everything is hung upon or,
uh,
proceeds from.
And so my business partner at the time,
we were looking,
uh,
at the saint,
so that came up for sale.
It wasn't the Saint Celia,
it was just no Victorian on an acre of land near downtown Austin.
And he's like,
what's the story here?
You know,
it's like you had to describe this to somebody.
And for me,
I mean it was,
I always loved that whole period of rock and roll that was about going to really
nice hotels and the super decadence,
not the throwing the TV out the window,
but uh,
you know,
great silver,
slightly tarnished been the white tablecloths from room service and the contrast
of,
you know,
Dylan taking
t somewhere or you know,
drinking a bottle of whiskey,
the stones at nail caught.
Um,
just that there's something so awesome about where elegance kind of meets rock
and roll and said there was this Victorian and it felt like the,
that I'd seen a photograph of like maybe it was a stones somewhere in like full
on 1970s,
um,
awesome,
uh,
you know,
clothing and there was a chauffeur,
washing a Bentley in the background kind of thing.
And so this place where those things met immediately became the Saint Cecilia to
me in the saint to say he was a patron saint of music and poetry.
And so if you ask where knocked chomp it comes from,
it's like that,
that smell of knock chomp is the,
is the hippie smell of that time and inputting it in a place as elegant as the
Saint Cecilia makes perfect sense to me.
So many questions.
I would think of myself in general as at least an aspiring minimalist when it
comes to certain aspects of design and uh,
certainly have very,
very limited experience compared to someone like yourself,
but have have had projects,
one in San Francisco before I moved to Austin where this place was stripped down
to the studs and it just became an art project and I've spent a lot of time in
Japan.
So it was a sort of a combination of like a green and green Eslan type feel plus
Japanese and a very simple in some respects.
And I have a particular dislike of,
of clutter I guess even though it's a ongoing battle in my own house,
I think it was your brother who said the following,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but let people be the color in the room.
Could you expand on that or explain what that means?
My brother,
Linden.
Um,
some of the best advice ever.
I think that,
you know,
you're looking at hotels at any point.
I mean,
particularly,
you know,
last 20,
30 years,
I'd look at someplace and I'm not given a bad shout out,
but yeah,
the loft or something or that indigo and they think design is fun and whimsical
and that is,
but oh my God,
how do you sleep in a play?
How do you walk through the hallway?
You're just assaulted by so many different patterns in so many different,
like what people think is like cool or hip or you know,
now.
And it's just like a constant onslaught.
Um,
and to me the best hotels or the best places are places that are more calming.
and so,
um,
doing things through massing or through a pattern where you,
you know,
take,
um,
the language of a place and repeat it and repeat it and repeat it and maybe so
settled that.
Know the people don't really notice.
But I think if you give people,
all of our own lives are so cluttered in so many ways,
um,
but if you strip away everything to a certain degree,
and let the people be the color in the room,
it's infinitely more interesting.
I think people feel better about everything that way as well.
You know,
when the San Jose is,
was the first hotel I did and I kind of think of it as a Jew.
Mexico means Japan is is for you guys who don't know.
It's um,
we did a real sort of minimalist,
um,
job on the place at the time.
We just,
we developed a furniture system that would work in,
um,
in the rooms because all the rooms are very different over the years.
They've been cut up in different ways.
So we needed something where we could,
uh,
use something repeatedly through him.
And we ended up using some,
uh,
pine loblolly pine,
which is a local lish material from east Texas.
And I'm in sort of a Judd lifeway,
Judd being the Marfa minimalist,
although I know he would hate the word minimalist,
but,
um,
which I think Judd is very informed by Schindler and I don't know if,
you know,
Schindler Schindler is an architect from the 20s that was working in the La
area,
but a very influential and with a very simplicity.
And so the San Jose has concrete floors,
um,
where we took out walls,
we put in an aggregate so you could see where the walls used to be.
Could you explain what that means?
Yeah.
So when,
when you,
um,
have,
uh,
old,
cement or concrete floor,
a lot of times when you remove a wall,
you'll have a hole in the floor.
So what we would do is we'd take 'em a concrete mixed with rock and fill it in
and then,
um,
and then sanded.
So there was,
instead of trying to fit in with the existing floor,
you could actually see the remains of the footprint of the dinosaur.
Exactly.
And so I'm the San Jose though,
although it's very simple with just wood and concrete.
And some people would think of as cold.
Uh,
there's a ton of plantings,
a ton of gardens.
It's,
has,
feels really lush and fill the sort of like living indoors and outdoors.
But,
um,
when we have comment cards and early on,
I really paid a lot of attention to come at cards and I'm sure the staff does
now.
But one of my favorite ones that I had up on the wall for a while was somebody
had written,
this is the most expensive fucking garage I've ever seen.
So what do you do in response to something like that?
Or do you not,
are you like,
you know,
not everyone's going to get it.
And that's okay.
And it's really hard at first because not everyone was going to get it.
And you have to decide if you want to please everybody or if you just keep doing
what you're doing and know that intuitively there's something that you will find
your audience.
Um,
and again,
I was very lucky in life to be in the right place at the right time because
Austin was changing.
And when we first opened the San Jose,
no,
just to not discount your skillset completely.
I mean,
you're in the right place at the right time,
but you've also now,
how many,
how many properties do you have?
Um,
maybe eight,
I think.
Yeah.
So I mean,
once you're lucky twice,
you're good.
Eight times.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
but you know,
but at that time with the first project,
you don't know what you don't know and you don't know.
I have a lot more confidence now.
Right.
I mean,
I had confidence then,
but not necessarily as a designer.
Um,
but I remember when we first opened,
we opened,
we opened in March,
which is,
um,
uh,
spring break,
but it's also south by southwest,
which is a huge conference.
You used to be more music centric,
but now it's tech and film and a lot of people descend on Austin.
There's not,
yeah,
it's gotta be,
I don't know the exact size now,
but it's gotta be 50 to a hundred thousand.
Yeah.
So there's not a hotel room in town.
Well,
we sort of did a soft opening,
which is crazy,
but uh,
what does that mean?
Soft happening?
That's where you invite people to that that might be friendly towards you or at
a very discounted price to a property or a restaurant.
And let,
let the staff practice on you knowing there's going to be some mistakes.
Um,
so opening during south by,
right before,
it was like February 14th,
and I remember February 14th was the first day that we had,
so it was Valentine's.
They had anybody that actually spent the night in the hotel and I put a banner
outside that we sold rooms for $69 for Valentine's Day.
And so that was the special,
and I mean like trying to just get people in the doors was,
uh,
was the whole point we opened,
you're in southwest.
Southwest totally sold out crazy because of course we had something in the,
something was in the,
uh,
waste pipe that was going to the street,
like an electrical fixture have fallen down into it.
So entire wing of the hotel flooded with sewage.
You'd have people who running out of the hotel with their standup bass or you
know,
whatever.
And there was no place to put them.
But
all right,
so it's in the middle of the south by complete chaos.
Everything is stretched to Max capacity.
Yeah.
I,
I'm sure that stress is running high for a lot of people who've flown in to
perform or whatever.
So you have sewage flooding,
half a hotel.
How do you handle that?
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
you,
you have to pay on the front lines of it and putting rubber boots and the whole
thing.
And again,
really,
you know,
I don't know.
It's,
it's hospitality.
Yeah.
Maybe usually people don't know this,
but behind the scenes we,
you a lot of places overbook knowing cause they're counting on cancellations.
Airlines.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so hotels,
you know,
the hospitality business is really interesting because hotels really are behind
the scenes,
usually most likely want to be friends with each other.
You know,
you can say it's competition,
but you're sharing information all the time.
Yield management and what's going on in town.
And,
um,
you just so you know,
a rising tide raises all boats to a certain degree,
but you're also going to have to walk somebody sooner or later to another hotel,
which means that you're going to,
you're going to pay for their room somewhere else because you've either
overbooked or mistake or had sewage flooding the room.
But there was no hotels to walk anybody to,
I don't know how we manage it.
Just put it out in my mind.
Now you've blocked it,
but if you try to unblock it though,
is there any,
what you say?
Did you get them to stay?
They're not sleeping on the street presumably.
So I think we did get them to stay.
I think that we went in and cleaned like crazy and disinfected like crazy and
remade the rooms all hands on deck completely.
You comp the room.
Yeah,
totally.
You know they say in the service industry a good recovery is going to make a
bigger,
more loyal guests then if you hadn't fucked up at all.
And that's true.
Yeah,
very true.
Because you'll tell 10 people if somebody really makes something.
Right,
right.
Well,
I mean that because everybody's all smiles and high fives when everything is
going smoothly.
And it's like how,
how do they handle things and do they own the problem when things go sideways on
their watch?
Kind of hard not to.
And that one must understand that.
It's hard not to own that one.
How dare you flood your own room with sewage.
Uh,
chip Conley.
Chip Conley is someone we both know.
If chip,
if you're,
if you're listening or so many passes this along,
miss you,
we'd love to see you.
It's been a long time since I've spent time with chip.
But,
um,
I've heard you describe him as a mentor.
I don't know if that,
if you,
if or haven't heard you,
I've read it,
so who knows if it's accurate.
But could you describe for folks who don't know the name,
who is chipped and,
uh,
what,
what have you learned or gleaned or observed from ship?
Huh.
So much over the years.
Um,
chip isn't mentors to,
to this day I signed last week.
Um,
for those of you guys who don't know,
chip,
uh,
started a hotel company called you out of Eve that was based in San Francisco.
Um,
and he started when he was fresh out of business,
go probably early twenties.
The Phoenix was his first hotel,
which was a motor court,
not unlike the San Jose or the Austin Motel.
Um,
and was a favorite of bands on tour musicians,
that kind of thing.
Chip continued to grow a very successful hotel company and decided at some point
in is around 50 or so.
I don't know how it was.
Chip when he sold draw to vive.
It might've been,
might've been right afterwards.
I remember I was at chips.
We didn't talk about this burning man camp.
Oh,
no kidding.
All right.
So was it Maslow?
Topia yeah,
so that's the only time I've ever been to burning man is really funny.
One of the yurts that was,
um,
you know,
the fold up.
Of course I did.
Uh,
that's wild.
All right.
So we were at the same camp at burning man and just didn't bump into each other.
Uh,
or maybe we did at the,
who knows,
like the catered ship food,
which by the way,
I mean it was such a conscious,
my first experience,
not digress too far,
but my first experience of burning man was trying to build a geodesic dome with
my friend on the spot that we had put together based on Internet instructions
when I was in San Francisco.
And then realizing none of it would fit together.
We ran out of water,
the,
our view we had broken down to the air conditioning.
Didn't worry,
it was just,
it was absolute survival mode.
And then,
and then I came to two chips and I was like,
oh my God,
this is like the four seasons of the salt.
I mean like he really,
he did the whole camp with some friends and basically you could get food at any
point you wanted.
There was a full service bar.
I had an air conditioner,
you know,
it was only like six feet across and it was made out of uh,
some kind of building.
It was like fold up it,
the whole thing folded up into
a very small package.
But it wasn't a bad way.
I kind of in and out.
Yeah.
That's so wild.
I can't,
we were there at the same time,
so,
so he sold,
he sold around here.
Yeah.
So was right to leave.
He's still a very young man by the way,
if you're listening chip and um,
he,
the guys from airbnb tapped him on the shoulder and said come help us a little
bit and what was helping in an advisory role for a while he became the head of
global hospitality for Airbnb.
And along the way he's written a lot of great business books that um,
we often have our managers read and like peak.
Um,
and uh,
the,
uh,
the emotional equation.
What is that book called yet?
You don't,
well,
I'll,
if people,
I'm blanking on the title,
but I will tell people that,
uh,
chips,
chips been on the blog on my blog a few times and if you search how to become an
effective CEO,
chief emotions officers
and my name or just search Tim Ferriss,
chip Conley and that'll pop right up with that book.
Right.
Chip has written many books and he is,
uh,
often has done a ted talk and is often a lecture on business and just on being a
more complete person.
And so,
uh,
chip continued throughout.
So the way I met chip is I cold called him.
I bought the San Jose,
didn't know what I was doing,
had no idea of what it was going to do and I saw his name like in a trade
magazine.
And so I called him up unbelievably.
He called me back and about 30 minutes.
Do you live voicemail?
I think I did.
I don't remember exact.
Yeah,
I think I did leave a voice and I how I got his number.
What would you have said?
I have this motel and South Austin and I just wanted to talk to you about it
quick or something like that.
But of course empl yeah,
of course.
I think he thought I wanted to see if he wanted to consider buying it.
Um,
but the fact that he called me back was,
I have cursed him for,
from this,
from that day to this day,
because now people constantly,
you know,
now they email me or some way ask if I could spend a few minutes and for advice
and you know,
that just aren't the hours in the day,
but he just pops up in my brain every time.
Like,
what would have happened had he not called back,
you know,
and I don't know.
But,
um,
over the years he was one of the first guests at San Jose.
He was passing through
and he came to see it after giving advise.
I,
I went and met him in San Francisco.
He looked at my numbers,
did,
I didn't really understand and tried to make sense of them,
but I could've had that conversation.
I could have that conversation now much better.
Um,
and then,
uh,
most recently we have a hotel in Baja,
California,
uh,
in a little town called Todos Santos right outside a little town called todos.
Santos dead is about 45 minutes from Cabo.
And he's the one that got me that because,
um,
he had sold his hotel company and a was not,
I don't know if I had a noncompete or just not supposed to be in the business
and he was very interested in the community and so he kind of pointed them in my
direction.
And now we have a really great hotel there and chip lives part of his life and
10 desantos.
Now,
what,
what other best practices or principles or do nots or dues have you picked up
from,
from chip or,
or other people?
Um,
actually I or had our president now at bunk counts.
I worked for chip for 10 years,
got named Christian struggle and um,
you know,
it's good.
Here's the thing,
you can be as creative as you want to be in dream as big as you want and create
an incredible experience and programming and everything along those lines.
But if you don't,
can't keep the lights on.
If you can't return money to investors,
if you can't keep your employees happy,
um,
then you're never going to have a successful business.
I mean you've got to keep the lights on,
you know,
and you've got to do a little better than keeping the lights on.
But,
um,
I think a lot of people fell in business because they don't have operational
rigor and that can be a lot of different,
that can manifest in a lot of different ways.
But,
um,
I think that chip was,
uh,
influential from early on about,
operations and,
and how important not just your guest was,
but your employee and your investor as well.
Okay.
The chip is up and peak.
You mean as it relates to Maslow,
uh,
muscles hurt,
hierarchy of needs and hence mess utopia as the name of the burning man camp,
uh,
is something that he would apply also to these various stakeholders.
Uh,
so another mutual acquaintance,
Larry McGuire of Mcguire,
Mormon group here,
many different restaurants.
Uh,
I texted Larry to ask him,
we know what topics or questions might I want to explore with Liz.
And he said,
oh,
well,
there's so many things you could explore that data.
But one of the things he brought up was the question,
how do you balance,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but it's not that far off.
Uh,
how do you balance wanting the desire to be an artist with the desire to be,
say,
a business tycoon?
Right.
It's really interesting question.
I mean,
it's such a balance.
I mean it is,
uh,
Larry is actually very good at what he does.
I,
Larry has several restaurants here in town and um,
I've known Larry since he was about 16 and started work for my brother.
Um,
but Larry is of those rare people that,
um,
understands both,
again,
rigor and operations,
which is going to be really important at the end of the day for somebody to have
the right experience and the artistry of creating an experience.
Um,
to me,
if you don't like people make hotels,
people design hotels and then they walk away.
And so that is always going to get diluted over time.
If,
if you don't remain involved in the experience or what your vision was in the
first place,
then what you created is,
it's not just an object,
it's a living,
breathing thing that has employees,
people that work there,
that spend their lives there.
It has guests that come and go as part of a ever evolving community.
And it has people that have part of the ownership and in the in the place.
So I think your vision is not complete if you just create something and walk
away.
Okay.
It is and other and other,
uh,
John Roas of art.
But in a hotel or in a restaurant,
it begins a new every day in a way.
And so
to create a guest experience that is right for that hotel takes,
um,
you know,
constant vigilance in a way and um,
and then is always going to translate to the bottom line.
I mean,
we don't mark it most of our hotels in a certain way,
but people aren't going to him.
For us.
Instagram is obviously great and um,
so are a lot of other social media platforms,
but we get a fair amount of print as well.
And that comes a lot,
not from us necessarily pitching stories but for people becoming real believers
in what we do.
And so I don't know if I'm really answering that question except to say it's a,
you have to have both things,
whether it's you doing it or someone else that believes in your vision and you
believe in,
there's,
you've got to have both the artistry and the beginning and the good practice to
continue in good business practice to continually,
uh,
tend the fire.
Do you have an idea of if you're going to be continuing to develop hotels and
put your craft
into the world in that way?
Do you have an idea for say how many properties you'd like to have in five
years?
Uh,
if you want to scale on a scale,
three years doesn't really matter.
I'm just wondering if you have some nice,
it's such a crossroads right now really about this.
Um,
you,
you know,
the pressure in business and the bigger your business gets is to grow,
grow,
and then sell it.
Right?
Dance seems to be,
you know,
I wonder if we'll look,
we'll be 30 years from now,
that won't be the thing.
Or if it was,
it wasn't,
you know,
50 years ago.
We live in a time where it's about growth and making your business worth as much
as you possibly can and then selling it.
And to me,
that's,
it makes no sense in the world to me because I'm a bit of a,
the journey is the destination kind of person.
And so if I'm,
I think that I'm both doing,
if I grow it at an enormously rapid pace about push,
not only myself,
but my team to grow as fast as possible,
we're not going to do the quality of work that we want to do.
Um,
and while we might have a higher value in five years as a company,
I don't think that the end game is to sell.
I,
and Larry McGuire I think,
believes the same thing I do in a lot of people that I look around dad and I'm
interested in their careers and their lives also are people that are interested
in what they do from now and from the people they work with day to day.
And I'm creating an asset,
like a hotel that can just get better over time rather than,
so you know,
we live in a time where you have hotels that they're ridden every seven years,
every five years there's a big,
you know,
big repositioning or whatever.
He's the most interesting places to me.
Just get better as time goes on and layer upon layer to texture upon texture.
Yeah.
Better not by reinventing themselves every seven years.
Exactly.
Was the second title.
Not a pattern language.
Thomas way of building timeless way.
But yeah.
So,
you know,
can you have a good life and make your [inaudible] have,
uh,
employees who are invested in that business and ha and also keep an asset,
and have it,
you know,
this,
I'm going to digress for a second,
but the hotel businesses,
we know it today is,
um,
as a result of a lot of things,
but we've come to a time where most hotels are not owned by the management
company.
So you have a group of owners and you have a management company that is a brand.
So from the four seasons to the Hilton to you name a Demariac what,
whatever it is,
um,
or even ace,
those guys over there,
great friends of mine,
every ace,
you look at his owned by different ownership group and uh,
you know,
you can talk all day long about why that is.
A lot of times the management company wants to say stay asset light because the
hotel business is,
uh,
you know,
in,
in waves.
So you don't want to get caught in a downturn owning a property centric,
mitigate your risk by growing a brand.
Um,
and that is,
um,
that easier or much easier when you are a Marriott and you're going to be the
same everywhere.
And you have in,
there was,
there was a time in the hotel business that,
or a time in hotels and those of us as consumers of hotels wanted that because
before that you could,
you know,
take a trip across country and all these hotels were independent and God knows
what you might find or might be delightful or it might be horrible.
And there was no way of judging the quality of a place.
And then we got Hilton's and holiday inns.
And what was great is that you could,
you knew what to expect and you knew the level of service for a cup of
Starbucks.
It's the same everywhere you go.
Yeah.
And we,
and so you,
you can depend on that.
I,
I'd read something from,
I was,
look,
the other day I was looking at some stuff about Hawaiian musicians in hotels.
You know,
why that loves story and they're interdependent in one way or the other.
And somebody was saying,
I don't remember,
it was probably Keith Moon or somebody who is well known for just totally
trashing hotel rooms.
It's like,
yeah,
it's the fifth.
This is the of the 20th fucking Holiday Inn.
You know,
we've woken up in and just as many days and they all look the same.
Anybody would be mad at it.
But,
uh,
that time is that time began to change with what we think of as a boutique hotel
or a lifestyle hotel from Schrager to chip Connolly.
You know,
I think you asked me about what are the next three,
five years holds?
What's my plan business wise or hotel growth wise.
Um,
and it's,
I feel like I'm at such a crossroads there and trying to determine what's,
it's not only what's best for me,
it's also what's best for the company,
but also the people I work with every day.
And so you want to grow because you want to be able to give the people you work
with more equity,
um,
more chance for more of a chance for um,
you know,
higher fulfillment moving into other jobs,
just all those things you want to come there.
I think that we have a natural,
a natural propensity toward growth.
But then the question becomes how fast and how much and what's,
what is the end game there?
And in this business,
I think in,
in this day and age,
people just mindlessly want to grow and explode.
The bigger you are,
the better you are,
the more people know about you,
the better.
But I think that a lot of the qualities that you appreciate appreciate it in day
to day living become lost.
And I think one of the reasons we're successful as a company internally at least
is because we are like a family in some ways.
And so how much can you maintain that as well?
I guess the answer is I don't want to mindlessly grow.
I want to thoughtfully grow.
And that may not be at the pace that a lot of companies would want you to grow.
And it's also about the in game.
And I don't think my end game would be to grow really fast and to sell the
business,
which is you find a lot of brands want to do now.
Well,
it sounds also to me,
just based on what you've been saying,
that your of Philosophical Lens through which you view your life,
which is the journey is the destination,
is a fundamental juxtaposition with what a lot of external pressures would want
to impose on the business.
Absolutely.
It's so tricky.
No,
it's,
it's such a balances and,
and it's a struggle in a way.
Um,
it is,
but,
you know,
some of it,
they're,
they're outside pressures are inside pressures.
Um,
but,
uh,
it,
it's a really good question because I'm in the middle of it right now and I have
lots of thoughts about it,
but it could go on and on and on.
But I do know that I could get hit by a bus tomorrow,
you know,
and,
uh,
and we all could.
And you're not going to care about that IPO,
you know,
five years from now.
Um,
my wife is pregnant and gonna have I,
I'm older and she's young enough to be pregnant clearly.
And,
um,
and that's a whole other life change also,
again,
when you see,
you know,
I do really am a big believer and the realization mortality,
I mean,
all those things really point me in the direction of,
uh,
living a quality life with,
in relationship to other people.
And in those ways,
I think it's,
you find meaning much more in a much more real manner,
then you find meaning in making a lot of money.
I agree.
I mean,
money's supposed to be fuel,
uh,
in a,
in a sense for transferring it,
transmuting that into other things like experiences and so on,
ostensibly,
right.
I mean,
it's a money as a representation of it.
That's it.
I'm not against money and it's super important for a business and it's super
important for the people you work with and for,
and all those things.
It's just the means to the end,
you know?
No,
it is.
I mean,
if we look at,
uh,
there's,
there's really fascinating book called a biography of a dollar or the biography
of dollar,
which walks through the history of money in some respects,
which becomes even more interesting when we start looking at more recent
develops it developments like crypto currency and so on.
But at the end of the day,
uh,
at least traditionally speaking,
it's a medium of exchange.
And so then the question is for one exchange for what?
Right.
Uh,
let me,
let me ask just a handful more questions,
uh,
because I think we could have many,
many more conversations
and hopefully this isn't the last,
uh,
we,
we mentioned a few books.
Are there any other books that you have gifted often to other people or re-read
allot yourself?
I love that you asked that question that way because,
um,
it really puts it in a different perspective.
It's like not what your favorite book is.
It's what you've given us this gift,
which I thought about a little bit this morning,
and I mean,
it's so clear,
immediate,
like I didn't have an immediate answer.
And then I had to think,
why did I do that?
But,
um,
it did,
I think when I was younger,
and it's still to this day,
I sometimes gift a book of poetry by Adrian Rich called a dream of common
language,
a dream of a common law,
common language,
which was a book written she wrote in the,
in the late seventies and she's a poet that,
um,
I was trying to think why it was that book so important to me.
It's really funny when I read Cheryl stray,
it's
wild.
That was one of the books that was most important to her that she had as she
hiked the Pacific rim.
That's right.
I totally forgot about that.
Yeah.
Um,
I gift a lot slouching towards Bethlehem,
a book by Joan Didion,
which is a collection of essays that I love that book so much.
And it's a lot about how,
what the kind of writing Joan Didion is doing in those essays are both,
you know,
of the time.
There's one about John Wayne.
There's you know about California,
but there's also this collection of personal essays.
She does,
that one's called on keeping a notebook that I go back to again and again,
and I share a lot.
There's one called keeping a notebook.
I'm keeping a notebook.
There's one called on self respect.
There's one morality,
but it's a,
it's an awesome collection of essays.
Um,
and there are other books by Joan Didion,
but that's when I tend to gift the most,
you know,
the other one that I'm sure people mentioned to you,
I can't imagine they don't,
is um,
when things fall apart,
but Pema Chodron is,
anybody recommended that has come up I think only once and up.
I'm Seth,
I apologize.
Uh,
miss tributing but he,
he does recommend Pema Chodron,
at least one of her audio books.
But no,
this was not a book that has come up a lot.
So if you could explain why so that bunks fall apart.
I think it's been important to me.
I've given to people in my life because it had an impact on me,
but it's,
um,
I don't know.
I could be wrong that it was,
um,
Pima children's first a shot across the bow.
I mean,
it might've been the first book she did.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but it was really my introduction into
the Pema children for the,
those of you who don't know as a Buddhist monk who became a Buddhist monk,
I think probably 30 years ago,
um,
when she had,
when her husband,
she found that her husband was having an affair and he left her and she was left
in this place of what to do about that.
And she kind of accidentally found her way into Buddhism.
But,
um,
to me it really revealed the struggle we have day to day of w in the face of
anything,
laws,
adversity,
all those kinds of things.
You know,
how much,
uh,
how,
we tighten up and struggle or we get angry,
we get bitter,
or we just continued doing the same things over and over.
The don't necessarily work.
Watching TV,
movies as an escape,
drinking even exercise sometimes that you have,
whatever it is we're doing.
Um,
and how,
uh,
we always think if we would just get to that next perfect place,
it would all be okay.
Like if we had the next job or if we moved to this new city,
or if we just had this relationship,
it was all be okay.
And then it,
as it turns out,
when you get to that place,
Lo and behold,
on the next horizon is you felt uncomfortable because you need this next thing.
And it's really the idea of,
um,
it did.
Again,
the journey is the destination.
Being able to,
to,
I'm on the way to that island role at rowing across the ocean.
You need to get,
find comfort in being on that boat and the roiling see it.
And then I did have him permanency and how I think anybody who's lived their
life with laws or death or anything of the sword understands what a,
Oh,
quite a jolt it is to figure to understand that things aren't permanent.
And then when we do accept them permanency of things and learn how to live in
the moment or on the roiling see and live with that discomfort,
uh,
it really changed.
It's a life changer.
And so when things fall apart,
I realized just in saying all that the Joan Didion book slouching towards
Bethlehem is taken from the same point,
the Yates poem,
uh,
slouching towards Beth.
What's it called?
Um,
is it slouching towards Bethlehem?
Right.
Oh God,
you're far more literate than I am.
I'm,
I'm failing my bio exam here.
We'll,
we'll definitely put things fall apart.
The center cannot hold.
It's a yeah.
Anyway,
puts a,
we'll put all of these in the show notes and we've talked about mortality a few
times.
Uh,
I've had quite a bit of revisiting mortality in the last few years with very
close friends.
And um,
uh,
even now,
currently,
uh,
some of you effectively family members and I have a coin that sits on my kitchen
counter or which says Memento Mori.
Remember,
you're going to die with iconography on it.
Uh,
coincidentally enough,
I should give him credit made by a friend of mine here,
Ryan holiday,
who's an author,
uh,
in the Austin area who writes a lot about stoic philosophy,
which is highly compatible with a lot of Buddhist thought and contemplative
practice in my experience.
In any case,
uh,
do you have a favorite,
favorite is a weird word to use here,
but a favorite failure or a failure that you feel like taught you a lot or set
you up for later success?
Um,
I've felt so often,
and I'm,
I've been successful very often too.
I think if you,
if it were a formative,
a favorite failure,
um,
but,
and again,
yeah,
you know,
sometimes don't,
we all feel like we're beating our head against the wall and he was like,
why am I doing that same thing over again?
I mean,
that's a whole,
I think it was still doing that.
It's a whole other subject.
But you know,
when I was young,
when I was in high school,
I was,
um,
I was in,
there was a thing called a youth in government and you from all over Texas that
they did.
And other states as well.
But you would learn about government by this kind of mock government thing.
And it came through the Ymc a tour and they were like little social clubs and
all of that.
But you think government was,
um,
something I got involved in,
uh,
when I,
probably when I was a sophomore,
junior high school,
when I was a senior in high school,
I ran for youth,
governor of the state of Texas,
which was,
you know,
it's a big state,
but you had to,
you had to run on a local level and then you had to run in a regional level and
then you came to state.
And my grandfather's a Tom is a rancher.
Um,
uh,
and one of the men I admire most,
um,
was at the time older.
And I think,
I think at that point he had broken his hip and he was in,
uh,
bedbound at home.
But as I ran for youth governor,
I would read the paper with him on a pretty regular daily basis,
if not every other day,
and discuss current events and current issues.
And it was an awesome period of time,
uh,
having those discussions with him and we came here to Austin for the youth and
government week and they do it,
they do it at the Capitol and they do it in the chambers.
So in the Senate and in the,
in the,
the House of Representatives and it's right after the,
uh,
the,
the real thing has led out and so you,
it's,
you know,
really awesome because you're in these great big hallways and all that kind of
stuff.
Anyway,
I ran for youth governor and the night that,
um,
there are already taking the vote and we're staying in a hotel right over here,
not far from here at all.
They're looking to over there.
And I was staying in a room with three friends who were there for the party for
sure.
I was very serious.
They were there to be in Austin and one of them had an older boyfriend who lived
here in Austin.
So they started drinking in the room and I knew that we weren't supposed to be
drinking in the room.
And so I left the room and went and visited some other friends down the hall and
they got caught.
And,
um,
we get called,
I get called to,
you know,
whoever our supervisor was and she said,
did you know they were drinking?
And I'm just like,
yeah,
I knew and I left.
Well,
it turns out that the whole thing was running on the honor system.
I'm sure I knew that at the time.
And because I did not report them,
I was kicked out and sent home with them.
And by that point they knew that I had won the election for youth,
governor of State of Texas,
which meant that like in the next year you were going to go to nationals and we
do all this stuff.
But instead,
so the morning of
the announcement,
you know,
went to the next person in line and I'm,
so he was sent home on a bus with them,
you know,
sitting with them.
And,
um,
when my mom went to report to my grandfather what had happened because he was
falling play by play,
he said,
tell Liz we're really proud of her.
And to me that was a,
this formative moment of realizing that there were rules and there was
authority.
Um,
and you know,
the honor system was what this whole system was running on.
And it was a system.
I was,
you know,
part cog and wheel.
And,
and I realized that he was really proud of me because I had grown up with
brothers and with,
you know,
a whole community that really believed that you didn't rat on somebody else.
You didn't call somebody out.
I was right to remove myself.
But I think there was a whole system of belief that,
uh,
I'd grown up with it if we've been wrong just to run and tell on somebody else.
And I think it was the first time that I,
you know,
over the years and looking back at it,
I think I learned more from this thing going wrong then it would have learned
from it going ride.
And it was about questioning systems in questioning values of just to,
cause somebody feeds says,
this is the,
these are the rules and this is what it is.
It doesn't mean that that's really the rules you need to incorporate,
you know,
as a great story.
What a lovely experience.
Also,
not that particular,
uh,
time in the capital,
but with your,
it was your grandfather.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
that sounds so great.
I never had that chance.
My,
uh,
my grandparents passed all of them when I was very young.
Yeah.
I was just lucky that way.
Yeah,
that's a name.
And we all lived in different states,
so even,
even when they were alive,
we only got to see them very briefly.
Uh,
you know,
just,
just a few more questions.
Uh,
if you had gigantic billboard,
metaphorically speaking,
right to on which you do.
So if you had an additional billboard,
uh,
on which you could put a word,
a quote,
a question,
anything noncommercial,
just a message to get out to millions or billions of people,
what might you put on that billboard?
Um,
we do over,
down by the San and the Austin Motel.
There is a big billboard,
but of course we rented to advertisers.
Um,
but on the side of,
um,
there are a couple of things on the side of Joe's.
One is that iconic,
I love you so much that people take pictures of all the time.
So it's a,
it's a longer story,
but on the backside of Joe's,
there is a quote from Jack Kerouac that says,
don't break your tenderness.
And I love that quote.
I think that's a good thing for everybody to remember.
Break your tenderness,
tenderness.
Yeah,
I love that.
I've never actually heard that before.
Now I think it's something we,
all this is right on the backside of Joe's on South Congress.
It's in,
when you're in,
when you're sitting there,
you can see it.
It's kind of blue on the,
on the corrugated,
so it doesn't bounce out.
Maybe we need to repaint it,
but it's been there since we opened it from,
I think Mexico City blows
in,
in a very real way.
I know you,
you wouldn't take full credit for this and there were macro forces at work and
so on.
But the fact that I,
the first thing I just thought to myself was,
wow,
I should go check that out next time I go for a nice walk down South Congress.
I mean,
if you hit,
not
looked out or perhaps gazed across the street from the continental and taking
the San Jose upon yourself as a project,
who knows what that neighborhood would look like.
I mean,
you had played a formative role in making it
what it is.
That's a big,
that's a big deal.
It is a big deal.
I mean it's,
it's an interesting,
we could talk for hours about that too.
You know,
I think it's about to change yet again.
I mean it would have changed and it would have grown and everything is always
changing and neighborhoods and always changing.
But,
um,
you know,
I think we were about to see an at home next wave of south congress salmon.
Oh,
I agree.
Yeah,
I'm excited to see it.
Yeah.
Well,
Liz,
this is so fun and I'm really glad that we finally had a chance to sit down.
Uh,
do you have any requests of the audience asks of the audience,
suggestions of the audience?
Anything you'd like to say before we wrap up?
No,
but,
uh,
no,
but I'm very excited about getting last days of the San Jose out there.
Yes,
yes.
And,
uh,
we were just chatting in between a brief a cut that we made about a handful of
things that probably need to be done just in terms of clearing writes music and
so on.
So for those people listening,
it might not be immediate,
but we didn't clink tea glasses.
So last days,
sooner than never have San Jose sooner than never.
Yes.
That is something that I think we're both comfortable committing to and people
can find you at the Liz Lambert on Instagram and Twitter at bunk house hotels,
Instagram and Twitter,
and a bunk house group.com.
Definitely if you're in the Austin area and if you're in,
have never been to Austin for God's sake,
take a visit.
It's a,
it's a very cool town,
the self proclaimed but believable,
uh,
live music capital of the world.
And,
uh,
it's been really lovely spending time with you today as well.
It really has been.
Thank you.
And for everybody listening and watching potentially links to everything we've
discussed,
maybe even the doc,
we'll see how much progress we make is available on the page with show notes for
this episode and every other at Tim dot.
Blog forward slash,
podcast.
And until next time,
thank you for listening and watching.